[Music]
all right in duped news yeah
submitted by ashy ankles I knew we're
all checking right now
oh yeah she's got a she unusually I
don't think we're pretty greasy so yeah
that duck grease yeah
pay less opened a fake luxury shoe store
as a social experiment what also they
took a regular pay less a store
rebranded it and see people's reactions
when they pick up their cheap-ass shoes
no so they took that's genius though
they took a former Armani store okay and
then they rebranded their shoes to look
like they were high-end so he's stuck
they snuck their shoes into Armani store
that's all that high-end shoes are doing
anyway yeah even high-end shoes are
pieces of [ __ ] shoes it's just this is
all brandings everything this is a
stupid experiment I mean but you're
smart not everyone knows that
Nordstrom's is an experiment and they
just they're still going yeah so they
did this in Santa Monica and they
invited fashion influencers party
celebrating to make fun of them oh la
see yeah they taste the name and they
rebranded it all like super high fashion
they did at our Shea [ __ ]
like when you target you call it target
that's funny so all the influencers they
didn't know [ __ ] oh my god I can't wait
I feel bad so I'm gonna show you guys
this video and they're gonna be playing
you think it me big alert
[Music]
we built a sick best I store in Los
Angeles
filled it with payless shoes the guests
that are Turkish you can't help herself
Ramona laughing they're elegant
sophisticated I just think it's so
classy
two hundred four hundred and even six
hundred dollars per pair will they pay
for it let's [ __ ] okay I don't feel bad
anymore why pay more when you can pay
less no when you pay palazzi these are
actually from bailiffs shut up now she
feel stupid she's like [ __ ] you I've
always said this too and I some people
get irritated because people people take
when I say this as saying like well I
can't have nice things what I'm saying
is brand perception is huge and on top
of that a lot of people buy things just
to say [ __ ] you I'm better than you and
that's those type of people yes they get
what they deserve no nobody but the
thing about this is this isn't an
experiment they're actually exposing
what the whole system is yeah they're
making a huge mistake doing that because
it's like this is all [ __ ] yeah it's
all [ __ ] like remember the storage
structure yeah structure like structure
was like it was like a men's clothing
store but it was like it was supposed to
be high-end yeah yeah and then they went
out of business and all their [ __ ] was
in JC Penney's yeah so all of a sudden
you went like so where the stuff is in a
store determines how you feel about it
right now that means the whole thing is
it's all a fraud yeah it's all a fraud
unless it's like handmade by a freaking
skilled like clothes maker or some [ __ ]
I just don't get it but you know like
you know when yourself you know when
you're holding on to something a good
material
yes that's like when you go to like what
stop what is that one store what do they
make like t-shirts no J crew paints god
damn it what's the name of that rush
like a gap but this
they'll be like $9 shirts in there a lot
of hmm-hmm
oh okay so when you go into H&M you
might see a $6 t-shirt right but that
[ __ ] is a $6 t-shirt yeah yeah it's a
where one time gym in Europe is
different from here cuz I got a pair of
jeans from there and then compared it to
the parrot like the same pair here the
quality is different so that what I'm
saying terminology is based off the
quality not based off when somebody says
what it would a brand a more intelligent
consumer yes because I think this they
think that they're being all smart but
to me they're just exposing how you
should be like well why am i paying for
anything in like Foot Locker or anything
like that it's all in your head
because there is like a quality
difference there's quality difference
you guys own a pair of payless shoes
they make your feet your feet my just
wraps it yes it just depends on the
brand yeah it depends on the boys hey
listen I grew up wearing pelo so did I
leave those and then it would wear but
there's brands within palest okay this
is just a store there's not a designer
Payless brand like like Shaq sold his
shoes and Payless rightfully so boy the
fact that you bought those you said of a
[ __ ] I couldn't afford Jordans and all
they got third grade I had to get those
you know you're just funny about that is
I never I was never a person and wanted
to spend $150 on shoes yeah yeah just
found it like I'm putting my feet in
this you know I play bass you make the
outfit though so depends on what your
values the outfit
it does this is why you're one of these
people if you're trying to fly this
video they got you too you would have
been in there like oh my god you know
but if you're into fashion then shoes do
definitely make the outfit but if you're
not into fashion then of course you're
gonna be like why I just up in this [ __ ]
and it's like oh you a knight but then
you have those like people who like you
know Dress for Less you know they they
know how to fix you up and then you
don't know like if you didn't know like
somebody if somebody told you that was a
five hundred dollar sweater are you
gonna wear
differently no cuz that's just not what
I that's not who I am I'm just saying
though like I'm saying like if you know
you wouldn't know unless like even that
adds to it so like I say you're like a
fashion person and you're like you know
they could do the same thing they're
gonna be like I'm gonna put you in
clothes and put you in clothes and then
like your outfit cost a thousand and
your outfit only cost fifty though yeah
psychologically they don't tell you
until you go like guess how this this
expensive fashion person you know did
default perception perception so it's
like I'm glad to think I love that look
on that woman's face like what cuz then
her whole world I'll just crumble yeah
she's being a phony yes the whole
dichotomy of like what she thinks it's
like hi I'm so important and it turns
out like because the real person would
break it down and go nope this fabric is
from this and this sucks and then
they'll look at that and go nah this has
not made well yeah like what this kind
of just shows me is not so much like
like we talking about it right so we
just talked about how like certain
brands have do care about the stuff that
they make right so things are cut and so
they understand that these quality
materials stuff this is just the dumb
ass consumer a hundred percent yeah I
mean those are like two different people
this is somebody who looked at something
and said I'm at a very posh party so
this is a very expensive thing yeah but
at the same time though that's still
that's okay too though because these
people were lied to also though that's
not that's in fairness to them in
fairness to them if I'm going to a place
that I'm being told that this is a
high-end place then I have it's okay to
have the assumption that it's gonna be
good quality stuff so you're gonna go
like you know if like if you know look
at if we were doing a store here I'm
gonna be like okay that shouldn't be a
hundred dollars for those chips you know
you know what I mean like this like this
just the perception is reality sometimes
so I don't mind that it's 5050 but if
you think about this way like how much
does it really cost safe for Nikes for
Jordans how much does it really cost I
have no idea maybe five bucks ten bucks
what I'm saying is like it's all
[ __ ] yeah
but the rule of thumb to use is how many
people agree with you that it cost
something so then for example like who
sets the price dictate these so-called
cuz I like luxury watches but I only
purchase Rolexes and the reason why is
because they have a high resale value
and a lot of people will buy it for
pretty close to what I got it for but
you know this is funny you say that it's
just like diamonds man just it's all a
scam right but diamonds are always all a
scam man it's all I saw what we have in
our head they're not handmade they're
made through machine men now but then
it's so most luxury watches the baby
value greatly once you buy it so you
can't resell it
so there's reasons like that I think
there's different reasons why people buy
luxury items for example like it might
just be status I think it's mostly it's
mostly status but I don't like buying it
but even with something the Rolex they
did they just have a name that's that's
what I'm saying so like yeah it'd be
what these people did it'd be like
having a store that said Rolex and you
go on in this like a Casio I can't tell
the deer fall if you pick up attachment
arises you know you'll be like well yeah
I thought that just was if they're not
enthusiasts they won't know there's no
way they don't know and that's why a lot
of people can pass off fakes
because there's some really good fakes
out there but people that know they know
the shoe the shoe game just because it's
like in palest doesn't mean it's a bad
shoe I'm saying like these companies
that make some of those shoes they just
have a different I don't even know I'm
not even familiar with I'm with you say
for sure for sure with shoes though
there are like there are bad shoes and
there are really good shoes dude like
those those things do make a fat
difference yeah and sorry dude
thank you you put your feet in some
ultra boosters and paler shoes there's a
two different depends are you gonna use
it to like again it goes with what you
value right and some people want the
quality or seem proper getting use it
for hiking or whatever it's like it all
depends what Shaq decided he said I
don't want to make a shoe that cost $150
to her I want to make a shoe that people
can't afford to get so they made a less
expensive shoe of good quality shoe and
he sold it in pay less I'm just
[ __ ] but I'm saying you still have to
have like that's still brand recognition
that's like if somebody has to come out
and say hey I know this is pay less but
I made sure that it was this I mean
that's what you're going for when you
have something like that you know you
these people are saying hey we're high
quality yeah I mean like that's that's
what they based the whole she game on
right now they they go this shoe is rare
it's like no it's made in a factory like
it's not rare but what about those
people that stand outside there's yes
that's what's been happening with the
whole shoot because you know even if the
Jordan was a hundred and fifty bucks
right they had a huge stock of it if I
wanted that shoe I could get it yeah so
now they do limited runs and so they
just did this whole value shift and
what's crazy is after it sells for $150
then online it's sold for 300 and resold
the end for 500 800 that's the crazy
part because I used to buy a lot of
shoes to a lot but then like three years
ago I was like this is the dumbest thing
I've ever done and I sold everything and
I'd only kept the ones that people gave
me as gifts so I just kept those and
those like that was Matt you know Matt
right yeah he had like a really
expensive shoe that you know there's
girlfriend bother my right one of those
expense and so he was he was gonna sell
them you know and it was like a thing
where you needed to have the Box the
original receipt you got to do all that
yeah because it cuz they say well this
could be a fake and that told me that
like oh this is all nonsense because you
know that's just what is that really you
know like so that makes it eight hundred
dollars as opposed or you know as
opposed to like oh 75 I think they want
the experience yeah it's like the thing
you're selling you're selling a dream
you're selling a fantasy and then those
people got duped
it's the resale so like if you don't
have the box and everything else they
receive that it's already used they
can't resell it for something higher so
people buy those expensive shoes not to
put on their feet they buy it from you
in hopes that they change the game by
turning it into a collector's business
or collecting stamps or baseball cards
or whatever it's like it's baseball
cards yes Cabbage Patch dolls I mean
that was it because Georgia shoes are
the most uncomfortable OTT of people
don't even wear them they just display
them yeah I have some Jordans I
and I was like oh these are terrible I
didn't like it just I didn't feel I
didn't feel secure I didn't feel
comfortable and I didn't like how they
looked and I was like honest those are
cases nothing you know what's
comfortable these sandals they're the
ugly things in the world there are 50
bucks be called Jaquez hocus I don't
even know what they are
you just hock them in a garbage cans
later it's one piece construction as you
can see mold it up from the same
material how much was it mold why like
New Balance 50 bucks sounds as a young
person now they've taken it over yeah
came back
[Music]